this netflix special that's coming out
right now
if you could objectively rank it it's my
best one well really wow this is my best
one okay yeah okay so and here's what i
liked how i wrote uh you know i was
always uh struggling with uh
uh my my closer on this one and then it
just came right at the last second i
couldn't like
i mean for
for like almost a year and a half i was
just like i can't figure
this [ __ ] thing out i just i knew
what i wanted to say story or it's story
okay and i knew how how i wanted to tie
it in but it just wasn't hidden
everywhere i went it was just long it
was too wordy it was just like i was
trying to cut fat and then it wasn't
getting what i wanted yeah i wasn't
getting the emotion that i wanted
and then one day i you know you ever
land on that one word that you needed
yep it's just one word
it's one [ __ ] word and it was this
one night i hit this word it just came
out of my mouth i was like there it is
and i i had it i was like there it is i
want to ask you the word but i you just
gave the best pitch for everybody to go
watch the special so i don't want
i don't want to know the word so that we
all go watch this oh thank you because i
have to go see it but there's a lot
writing on this word
yeah the adword
and we'll be right back after these
messages
sorry about it
sorry about that
okay so best special best special now
here's the question
how do you
develop now that you're doing because
i'll be honest i found it hard like this
was my first tour where i started to do
what i think are bigger venues they're a
fraction of the size of the venues you
do but i think are pretty big and i
found it harder to work out on the road
yours are big
they're not the [ __ ] volcano
in hawaii yeah okay but but at the same
time i remember when you were doing this
dude i remember watching you go from
clubs to theaters to [ __ ] arenas
and i remember seeing that that jump it
was it was really unbelievable and uh
but
what i'm curious is is are you working
out in clubs i remember watching you at
a club just working out and my mouth
dropped
and i hugged you
i hugged you that night where were we it
was gotham oh my god yes yes it is
before i even knew who you were i didn't
even know you were [ __ ] with
charlemagne or anything and i walked
right up to you i ran up to you
oh yeah and i hugged you and i was just
like you're [ __ ] brilliant i hugged
you tight i remember that yeah yeah man
when i see someone that's just like
extremely he's a [ __ ] dude i didn't
forget it i didn't forget it i didn't i
remember yeah you forgot it's fine but
that's the same [ __ ]
that's your clothes
no but i remember i i just i love
watching uh
a comic that uh
i don't know like i love comedy so much
yeah and you know when someone's being
genuine and like and like you can either
have a story to tell that's very uh
genuine or you can be your genuine self
on stage because as long as you're doing
those two things then you're to me
you're a comedian yeah when i see you uh
when i can actually see the words on the
page come out of your mouth yeah yeah
yeah then then i i stopped listening
feels like you're reading yeah i stopped
listening to you and then and then when
i don't see like uh
like uh
like i know when you're ad living and i
know when you're improvising i know yeah
yeah and i can also watch your act this
is just me all right don't but i can
watch someone's act and i can already
write a tag and
and i can also get a call back in there
yeah while you're on stage yeah
and when i'm on stage i like to do that
yeah so like when i'm when i'm talking
and it hits it comes out right away i
don't i don't censor myself yeah it
comes so when i see that i i get really
excited yeah yeah yeah because i
remember watching you that night and i
was like oh
this is special oh thank you yeah and
that was like i think that was like 10
years ago yes it was probably a while
now or eight years ago yeah right maybe
before you came on brilliant idiots for
the first time yeah but even then that
was like years or years after yeah yeah
yeah i remember hugging i still remember
what you were wearing what was that
wearing you're wearing a denim jacket
and dark like dark pants
yeah dark pants and a denim jacket and
you and you had to hurry up and go to
another spot
and i just was like oh that guy's good
there's a lot of guys i see i saw before
the pandemic i saw uh i was you know
because i like to go up at like open
mics and [ __ ] dude i love that i saw you
go up at one in hawaii yeah i grew up i
did one in the philippines and it was in
the basement it's like some pool hall
and i went up and then uh
and then the two guys that went up
before me they were funny i was like hey
you want to go up in an arena and i put
them up in my area
yeah that's so cool how did they do in
the arena
they ate [ __ ] but like
but you know what i mean yeah
all right
they ain't [ __ ]
they ain't [ __ ] and he's
i'll go up anywhere i know and then are
you doing material you're just riffing
no i'll just riff yeah are you not
worried about the pressure of all these
people that admire you oh one time i was
in cleveland and i was doing something
and opened my thing and i pulled my my
tour bus in front of an open mic i love
it that's so sick it was so fun i got
out and it was like
i was next to a tv set yeah yeah it was
like they had like these fold curtains
that to separate the bar from like yeah
where i was going up and and i went up
and then i got everyone on my bus i put
those comics on the bus and then we went
and uh yeah it was fun but uh
but i saw i was this is for the pandemic
before the pandemic i went to a pool
hall
right yeah
they were doing open mic and the big
pool table in the middle of the room and
then off in the corners where the
microphone was and i was i was about to
go up this good good-looking guy with a
mustache
muscular is just
killing it
killing it and i was just like oh oh
[ __ ] i'm gonna [ __ ] with this guy who is
this guy he's crushing yeah and he gets
off stage not going because i had to go
up after him
and then and he he got off stage i want
to talk to him when i get off stage so i
went up and i got it and he was gone
and i'm like i was asking the guy i was
with i was like do you know good looking
the guy would be with us i don't
remember his name and he i guess he was
just a surprise set or he just went up
his name wasn't on the list
and no one would tell me his name and
then
and he haunted me for like six seven
months and then all of a sudden i went
to
netflix and he pops up
he was on like some stand-up special and
it was mateo lane i got
i go that's him and then i dm'd him that
night
i dm'd and i go yeah i go bro you're
[ __ ] brilliant and when this
pandemic's done i want to [ __ ] with you
yeah and uh seriously yeah this is how
progressive you are that matteo lane you
describe as handsome with a mustache and
not gay
yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah
and i go i wanna [ __ ] after that and we
remain friends yeah during the pandemic
we love mateo yeah he was incredible
yeah and then i got i had him open for
me at brooklyn
and uh and then he's gonna he's gonna
open for me at madison square garden wow
when are you doing garden i want to come
to that uh november 10th you have to buy
a ticket
i'll support
oh that's the weekend of uh the big
fight
the 10th is thursday right i i don't
know oh yeah it is yeah it is yeah yeah
huge fight izzy style bender oh is he
yeah man i love him stay in town yeah go
watch the fight well i i you have other
shows
it's that weekend right yeah so you're
there thursday yeah i'm gone you have to
leave yeah he has other arenas to do
yeah yeah
can you tell the story real quick about
um
well i'm going to shout out some more
guys oh yeah yeah go go jr de guzman uh
andrew lopez
uh uh and of course matteo lane uh those
are my favorites yeah like those guys
make me ooh
like uh beth stelling yeah like those
though when i see them i'm like ooh i
like that i like what they're doing can
you okay now can you tell a story
yeah yeah okay yeah so it's gonna be a
real one no this is this is well i don't
know you gotta tell me when this is a
real story would you want this to be a
real this is a real story
this is a real story this is okay ready
okay yeah we're gonna i'm okay
um
now i feel pressure to do a fake one
but it was real that i what i wanted
before yeah okay it's the story about
when you were i think taping the the
netflix special for the first one and
you didn't like the first set and then
the second set
you just kind of like winged it in the
beginning yeah that the first set i was
so pissed yeah yeah yeah that's when i
cried and this is when you put up all
the money they were like we're not gonna
buy it so you know where to go with that
i had nowhere to go and then the first
set it was just everything was [ __ ] up
man that's why if you're gonna if you're
gonna do if you're gonna tape right the
cool thing about that is i learned
everything yeah and it's just like you
know
what you shot your special right yeah
and like you know the like you learn
things like you watch other specialties
we did four shows on purpose yeah you
have to yeah i'm like the entire
audience you know that right you have to
yeah yeah i i i had microphones in the
second balcony all the way to the back
smart that's why people go oh he's got a
laugh track i was like no [ __ ] i
got everyone's laughter on tape 100 i
got it yeah so um but like i remember we
we shot that first one that's so smart
by the way because sometimes comics put
out these specials and it sounds like
they're bothering yeah they're picking
up all the audio from their hands it's
like what are you doing you need to
recreate the sound of the room yeah the
only way to do that is to have
microphones in every [ __ ] room and
it's so funny because i i studied every
kind like i only watched the the
specials that i enjoyed watching to
learn how to shoot my special
and the
what i fell in love with on sound was
dana carvey's
i saw dana carvey i go this doesn't
sound real
i go what is this like this i feel like
i'm there and then i i gave it to my uh
my sound engineer yep and he goes oh he
he just added more mics that's easy dude
he goes most most specials they only do
like two boom mics on the stage and then
stupid because then you're just getting
those front people in the front
throughout the whole thing it doesn't
sound full yeah and those data went all
the way to the back and i go well
whatever dana got double it
you know who who else did [ __ ]
amazing sound design was uh when bird
did the the theater in england the royal
albert or something like that nice and i
thought because the bigger the venue the
harder it is to do this way harder yeah
because you're starting to catch the
echo of the mic as well as the audience
and you got to like you know
find a way to separate those two
whatever but um
and the way that he did his in a venue
that size with great acoustics sometimes
venues that have good acoustics i don't
understand that yeah yeah yeah yeah dude
like i play like i'll play i'm sorry to
switch right i just don't understand we
live in a time where we got computers
yeah everything that you need you can
you can base
you can base the design of your room
just by going to the perfect theater
yeah yeah okay you guys have perfect
sound okay let's get the best engineers
and let's figure this out and we'll make
it over here yeah no one wants to do
that yeah you go to san antonio it's
like you're playing in a [ __ ] ice
cave
it's like what is wrong in here i put
every [ __ ] microphone in here we
bought extra speakers we brought
everything and it sounds yeah awful you
know what michael go to you go to
phoenix i'm just telling you right now
you go to phoenix and you play uh around
uh no no uh uh that's celebrity uh where
i i play arenas i'm sorry sorry that's
right i'm so sorry where they play
basketball basketball yeah yeah yeah
yeah
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
that is the best venue i've ever been in
interesting yeah it was incredible i
couldn't believe it it felt like i was
playing a comedy club yeah it's i forget
what it's called but where the sun's
play yeah
incredible yeah yeah
yeah
what never mind no you're doing that
thing no i'm not doing thank god no
you're doing this is incredibly
important to me the sound for comedy
special specifically yeah he's obsessive
about that
good i i am absolutely obsessed with it
even when i started putting out clips
originally i was like yeah this is the
differentiating factor it's like well
obviously you need to have the jokes and
all these things need to be there but if
i feel like energy exchange between
comic and audience is integral to
enjoying it at home and if the comic
looks like he's giving too much and the
audience isn't giving enough even if
they are yeah but it feels as if they're
not yeah there's this awkwardness that
you feel
yes and i don't ever want somebody at
home to feel that awkwardness and also
people who get it sorry but the people
who get it who have done it what done
well
the the comics who who've done it well
the people who watch the special don't
realize what's happening they just go i
just really loved watching that yeah
it's an unconscious reaction for them
and that's something that we need to be
aware of yeah because they don't know
exactly what's happening they don't know
they're being brought into the room
literally the beginning of the special
we just put out the first few lines is
turn up the volume on your tv it's
specifically been designed to bring you
into the room and
yeah i just love that you paid attention
to it yeah and i also think that
sometimes the old rooms i like how you
light up your room okay go on that well
i just know that one your crowd work is
you know spot on that's like that's your
signature
um you'll by the way oh
my crowd break is [ __ ] amazing no
yours i was just about to say where
where's my camera i was just about over
there right yeah it's right back there
yeah
yeah i don't know which one to look at
they're all red so right here absolutely
so this one yeah just that one just
look at that camera right there
yeah yeah yeah yeah
but yeah you have to like them oopsie
what a shame yeah
do you have to show them but i think
sometimes the old venues
that have the acoustics they're
basically built before uh
technology yeah they were built when
people were just talking yeah 2 000
people or 2 000 people now you don't
have to deal with these things but
sometimes when you put speakers in there
because the acoustics were so good
naturally yeah it echoes like crazy when
you add the speakers mm-hmm that's the
tricky thing
with the suns it's it's a lot easier
yeah because they're used to loud noises
but then there's also those venues that
were made like 70 years ago and it's
just like [ __ ] perfect well when did
we get like
bob hope theater i think it's called in
like i don't know where it's at but i
just remember talking to the guy i'm
like how old is it is like charlie
chaplin used to perform here and i'm
just like yeah this is incredible he
didn't like yeah he was silent yeah how
did they even why would they have no
sound he wasn't mute yeah
he was a music do you think he was a
mutant look at me look at me hey
hey joseph that was maybe the worst uh
example of a performer that you could
have possibly used for sound do you know
what i mean
they captured me also quickly i got
every footsteps
[Laughter]
i'm not gonna say this but i think he
also did uh charlie chaplin like an
unplugged which was like a reverse
where he actually spoke like a nirvana
it was like you know he's like i know
you guys you came to see me live yeah
you don't want to see me quiet cause
that's what you always see this is me hi
i'm charlie oh
[ __ ] yeah and they have that it's on
blu-ray i was also wild to see an asian
person go hi i'm charlie
but yeah shout outs to charlie chaplin
dude um big inspiration for you like he
was one of uh
one of the reasons why i do stand up
yeah
yeah
yeah now he was dude do you know what i
mean yeah man okay classic question yeah
okay uh
if not stand up
is there any other uh form of
entertainment that you think that you
would succeed in
um
directing
so behind the camera what about in front
of the camera
um i like it i don't i don't mind it but
i really love i love
stand up yeah and if i'm going to be in
front of the camera i want to i want to
perform that way yeah yeah yeah yeah but
behind the camera i love it yeah do you
want to direct stand up special yeah for
other people yeah we're already in the
works so really yeah cool can we talk
about him well after no we can't but
yeah
you know we want to get these deals done
yes and uh and i'm going to knock it out
apart because i'm going to do it the
right way yes yeah you get it yeah you
get it i love watching what you did was
incredible man that was cool thank you
man yeah but yours was awesome thank you
buddy thank you i love i love i love it
when uh when people uh share the light
you know yeah it's beautiful i like
seeing you with the platform that you
have and the and the
and the
the that what do you call this
this is beyond i don't even know what
this is what you've built is just
amazing we built it this is a big i know
but you you say that all the time and i
love that man yeah that's such that's so
cool and and your team is what makes you
who you are and uh so fun that way cool
yeah man like i don't understand these
gatekeepers bro yeah yeah that old
school mentality is just so lame i'm so
sick of it i wish you would shout out
your team more that was one of the
things that i yeah yeah yeah i thought
about before well you were on my team
and then what happened um man you too
specific right
yeah
i don't like filipinos
dude i really thought ted serranos was
filipino yeah you said that because the
name could be filipino yeah excellent
bass oh but i've never seen his face
yeah oh you haven't no no it's not like
that ted's very nice by the way no yeah
great guy yes he is i like him yeah ted
is a figment of my imagination he exists
in the ether somewhere
but it's okay you know what i mean stop
price what are you gonna do
disgusting that's an animal right no
tolerance just an animal yeah
um uh ukraine or russia which
uh how many more commercial breaks can
we do that's an easy one that's actually
an easy one yeah like have you thought
about which side you're on like is that
a pretty clear side yeah man yeah yeah
yeah man yeah so
you know what i mean
right
that's the best way to answer a tough
question jesus yeah man yeah totally
dude
totally dude i totally you won russia
hey 100 100 dude like you know yeah yeah
yeah
that is that is hey what is your
favorite number
mine yeah you know what it is what is it
seven
is it no
but isn't there like a superstition in
tagalog
oh i knew that this was gonna go
somewhere when i started this line of
questions because you saw the eight on
my arm yes did you see what i just did
i've chosen one listen
okay
the wrong number yeah yeah why is uh
seven the most dangerous number i don't
know because seven eight nine [ __ ]
wow
you know what i said earlier i don't
like those guys i don't know
i don't like it yeah
[ __ ] dude oh that's because i like you
too much i can't i i can't be mean